in five four three two one what's up
everybody to an episode
of the genius brain podcast uh konichiwa
ohayo gozaimasu uh
this is a midnight talk we are having
basically yeah this is a very very very
late night talk i've been trying to get
these podcasts in
so i could keep you guys continually
entertained
yeah you know you've been working a lot
working out a lot lately
working out ah you know i've been trying
but you know
it's really sad i don't see the result
only because i eat
so much not these days i'm glad you know
that about yourself well it's because
somebody cooks
all the time nobody forces you to eat
though i don't understand what you mean
by that every time you say that
i i don't have a let's have an example
yesterday
you air fried hamachikama which is
yellowtail collar which is
quite healthy fishes have omega-3 fatty
acids
it's high in protein i didn't hang on i
didn't say it was not healthy
okay and he was like hey i'm gonna cook
all of these i was like cool
and he asked me would you like some and
i said no thank you i already had my
dinner
uh-huh so after he cooks all of them
i'm reminding my own business and
you're like this is so good i don't know
why i would go
to a restaurant and pay for this i made
it so good
that's exactly what i sound like yeah
that's very accurate go ahead oh this is
so good though
he did he sounded like a mom this is so
good
he asked me do you want some and i said
no i'm okay
he ended up coming to me giving me
at least a little piece so i could try
his food
exactly a little piece how little was
that piece describe to me
describe to everybody the size of the
piece that i gave you right now the
point is
if you ever had a dingleberry out your
ass that's how small it was it was just
this dingleberry piece of fish
and you're talking about i'm stuffing
you that that little piece of fish
probably had at most
five calories i don't want to hear that
you were stuffing me i
love your food so yes part of it is my
fault the fact that i can't
control myself and have your delicious
food
also you have what we call conson
which means you have big hands that's a
literal
definition of it but what it means is
that you like to cook a lot
like you cook like we have a huge family
like a family of
three kids i know i have two breasts
and i have so i have a big belly in
order for those food not to go
bad as well i have to eat faster or more
you don't have to do anything my dear i
don't like wasting food
you know the thing is that the way we
cook the amount of portion
is very different you cook like you have
a family of five i cook like i have a
family of one
so usually things but we but we cook it
and then we store it in the freezer
to save it for later until you put in
the fridge and you forget because our
fridge is so
yeah but but remember what happened
though we didn't go shopping for like
almost two
to three that is why we didn't and now
we got
no food in the fridge and all we're
eating is
i'm eating eggs eggs and ramen
i'm eating eggs and bread well i don't
understand why you just can't say no you
don't have to eat the food
i love food i love exactly so it's not a
meat thing it's a you thing i didn't you
need to practice self-control my dear
which i admitted
i know i admit that i said that because
i also love
food but you were saying that the reason
why i didn't yes you did
it's reported part of the reason maybe
you should go rewind this and hear
saying yes i'm not part of any problem
dude i'm the solution
solution to what a happy life happy life
that's right you're saying that i have a
happy life
i do exactly exactly you do i do
you have a very happy life very
stressful
time to time you have a very you have a
house husband that just
cooks and cleans all the time uh cooks i
don't know about the cleaning part
as you know everybody
you cook i can throw you into the middle
of a lake
did you not cut did you not come down to
a kitchen that was
clean today after i used it
did you did you did you after i used
about 600 days we have lived together
okay after that okay hold on a second
hold on a second i swear to god every
time i have you on this podcast
listen to me i'm changing the name of
this podcast by the way when you're on
hold on a second okay okay after the
last podcast because
your fiance does something we call
active listening
okay i actively listen yeah i realized
there are two
types of listening from you i actively
listened to this
and what happened you see you see any
ramen bowls with soup inside it
no my dear i washed that [ __ ] up and i
threw that [ __ ] in the dishwasher that's
right i am so
glad i noticed it too and i acknowledged
it i was like
exactly did you put the dishes away so
now
i'm literally two paces away from being
perfect so at this point
i don't want to hear nothing from you
right at this point okay
after one day actually one morning
okay but you know what kudos to you once
one step at a time
one step forward is a step in the right
direction exactly and i'm like
everybody one step forward is a step
in the right direction thessalonians 5
18 4 16 divided by 2.
1.2 one step forward
is a step in the right direction
all right pastor so okay go and have
your own mosaic now when god
came when god when god came down
and he looked at us see we were created
in the image of god we were created in
the image of god amen
right god doesn't expect perfection out
of me god expects me just to be a
reflection of his image and try my best
to do so
if not it's not about
that it's not it's not about me to shut
up it's not about perfection
because one step forward is a step in
the right direction are you laughing at
god right now
i swear i swear to myself
wow that was amazing thank you that was
a great performance i told you i used to
be a pastor i know i still got it in me
gosh oh you made me cry right there amen
hallelujah amen
copy and paste today's morning to every
day you know i i do want to say this
though
just because i've been hearing i've been
hearing a lot of
you know far far be it that she and i
are anywhere near close to being perfect
we're not we're we're a hot disaster
especially the
the the trials and tribulations that
that we went through just to get
to where we are right now and she does
some stuff that still pisses me off
absolutely but um
dude late night muriel's weird huh
you want to talk about that let's talk
about that farting thing you have been
farting so much recently it's unreal
excuse me
i fart at night you fought in the
morning that's
what it is my dear you fart at night you
fart during the day
you fart during brunch you fart during
prayer you fart
you fart during siesta fiesta everything
dude it means
circulating i would think that the
amount of fart that you had you would
just start flying in the air how much
you fart
i'm tell because we don't have food too
nowadays i'm eating a bowl of edamame
every night
that's a bean that's a lot of beans
you've only been eating
edamame for the past couple of days yes
and you've been [ __ ]
what are you saying for the past you've
farted so much
it means it's circulating very well down
there and
hey and i like when you fart too you
just you're just stone cold face too
you're hoping that i don't even notice
but the problem is it's not that her
fart smells it's it doesn't smell the
fart is
violent it's violently purple
her fart is as violent and loud as a
prison outbreak
that thing it rumbles the earth you know
every time
but it got no smell which on the other
hand
this man when's the last time you
smelled my fart
i don't know exactly smells in the
morning
it's not that's not fart smell dude
that's not far smell though that's
natural man's smell morning i'm like
what the hell is this that's not that i
swear i had the candle light on
last night where is my my glade candle i
turned it on for
hours hoping that it would save the
morning
but no it doesn't so here's the thing if
any ladies out there have not lived with
a man
if you have not had a male sibling if
you have not smelled your father's room
in the morning for some reason i don't
know what it is and i only know this
because when mario lived separately from
me when i walked into her room
or when we when i spent the night only
one night in her bedroom the room
smelled fantastic
for some reason men exude this stinky
odor out of their body it's all guys do
you smell it
i smell it it just smells like dude like
like the exhale of a dude
how do you smell it it doesn't smell
nice it's just like oh this is weird so
you know opening up the windows helps
out a lot
but i don't know why men smell so much
worse than women because you know me
every night before i go to sleep what do
i do yeah you're a very clean i shower
yeah
i shower i brush my teeth i do
everything two three times a day
and then but in the morning it just it
smells like man oil
and you don't smell it throughout the
day too exactly so i don't know what it
is at night
maybe i'm farting at night huh probably
you fart a lot at night and you talk in
your sleep
you know what you should sleep it's a
very like you should do it's a very
scary experience for me at night
i just keep on hearing these howls come
out of your ass and your mouth
all hears it and then i hear it
i still smell like flour though you know
what you should do you should wear your
cologne you should wear your cologne at
night no because i can't sleep
you know when you wake up in the morning
before you go to work i never told you
this
because i don't wanna hurt your feelings
but when i wake up you know why i wake
up in the morning
is because right next to the bed before
you went to work you would do this
i would wake up to the smell of a
thousand poppy flowers
like why would you why do you just i
don't i never understood why you would
decide
to douse yourself with perfume right in
front of my nose does this smell good
i don't want to wake up i can't breathe
if i had your smile i would sleep so
fine
not your smile your cologne i can't if i
had your cola i'd be like
but that's why they i think they say too
not to spray on cologne or perfume
before you go onto a plane because it
bothers people
i could see that because if you have
multiple different cologne
mixing up that would smell horrible yeah
but you didn't get that fart in check
though
blood fart crazy you know we should
really stop talking about fart i feel
like you talked about that way too often
i don't think so man
we're gonna get food guys we're gonna
get down here we love food
and that is why hey if it consumes it
gotta execute somewhere okay
execute yes you mean exit yes
let's go say some random words that
don't make any sense
if it consumes it gotta execute
something
if it consumes it gotta execute they
gotta
execute you just stephen a smith you're
just saying random things
long day today like taking so long i
thought i was gonna pass out and i'm
here
talking a lot it gotta execute
because sometimes when things leave the
body it got a recipe
he got a recipe my life don't steal you
ever recipe something and then you
configurate it
because when i configurate something you
gotta recipe it cause we're gonna
execute
hey mister pastor so you got your line
in the beginning that is my line okay
i'll take my line thank you very much
where are you right now are you even
here you're like you're literally in
another universe i sure am
the night mario becomes aerial song
it's what my [ __ ] news right now
you're [ __ ] high [ __ ] you're high as
[ __ ]
no my um so my co-workers my
my ex co-workers the people who i used
to work with
they used to they saw my photos when i
was in college or like in my early 20s
and it's like all these photos at the
clubs and they're like what the hell
mary used to drink and i'm like
that's a drink and so i would tell them
all the stories that i would
what i you know the events i would go to
and stuff
and they're like oh the night muriel is
the ariel
and i was like what it's like the ariel
song is coming out because when i
at nighttime i get a little bit loopy
and they've been in my car before when
i'm a little bit loopy
and i'm not the best driver i will admit
i am not a great troll
you are a terrible driver and so when
they experience that they're like
you're never allowed to drive ariel
she and i used to get into so many
arguments because girls are the funniest
it's not just marielle too ladies you
gotta explain this to me right
i don't understand how every girl that
i've dated i've been with
or have been friends with every time you
guys almost kill somebody in the middle
of the road
your reaction doesn't make sense for the
fact that you almost committed [ __ ]
murder
like you you'll swerve into six legs and
you go oopsie
it's not it's not oopsie you're almost
killed like
a dramatic guy you i don't know but the
answer is
i don't know if i knew then i wouldn't
be doing that because obviously it's
not great when we first started dating
too one of the biggest things that she
used to do she used to get highly
defensive
even when it came to stuff that she she
you're not you're not that bad yeah
because i gave up
you're not that bad you're not that bad
she would get highly defensive for
things that she knows she's bad at like
the driving thing right
and i told her too because i openly
admitted from the beginning that i'm not
a good driver
right but my driving compared to her i'm
a nascar driver
okay buddy yeah yes buddy crazy
actually i i was gonna say i don't have
a crazy road rage but
my road rage compared to yours mine is
like god
but we're not talking about road rage
we're talking about driving skills i was
just talking about the dramatic
drastic comparison if i get rid of your
backup camera what happens
i will able to drive
what kind of question is that i've had
that camera for the past 10 years
of course i can't drive have you ever
driven a car without a camera yes i did
i have my honda civic
ex 2006 by
[Laughter]
you're only doing podcasts in the middle
of the night now
what's wrong with you i love olivia i'm
trying to get you
dude this girl is so funny i'm just
aside from this just mentioning her car
she told me that when she first had her
car right
she was so worried about getting sued
this is this is how different she is
from from from me like when we drive our
friends around we drive other people to
school yeah
have any of you ever made them sign a
waiver
let me explain she had people sign
waivers before she went into her car
if you ride in my honda civic ex
2005
you need to sign this i need your
parents to sign this waiver to say i
am not liable for your safety hey let me
which was a smart idea because she
drives like she's sonic the hedgehog
yes i admit and yes let me explain that
at first
i did not do that you know what i just i
just pictured you making the parents
sign the paper
they go of course and they sign it and
as you're backing out their driving you
hit their garbage can
at their mailbox and then you run over
their five-year-old brother and you
drive off
that is horrifying but no i never done
that i never got into any accidents
where i get sued
um let me explain let me explain okay in
high school
when i got when i got my car i was
actually a great driver you know what my
driver tests
i don't know what do you call them what
do you call them dmv
the driver's test yeah yeah the person
who tests your drivings
um that person said wow it seems like
you know this car so well
like and she was so impressed by my
driving skill because i was
great at it and so a lot of people
a lot of friends and their parents knew
that i was a great driver so they asked
me as a favor
like hey can you become the uber for our
kids
this is before uber this was before uber
it was
and i did fine it was great and all and
then later on
unfortunately there was a huge accident
that happened you didn't no not from me
uh
some of the classmates some yeah some of
the classmates they went on a trip
and then there was a huge accident and
unfortunately one of them died
and there were four kids in there
and what happened is that one of them
died which was a good friend of mine
the other friend got into a coma had to
do multiple surgeries
the driver came out safe did they go to
jail
no but all the parents
sued the driver which was a student
and that was a huge deal because
i mean think about it like she was just
driving
and what happened was that she was
driving she was making a u-turn
and i don't know whose fall it was but
then a bus came and hit the car
and hit the passenger seat and the
backseat
so after that well i mean clearly the
the kid would have been at fault in that
case because
if well if if the bus driver was at
fault the parents would have sued the
bus driver because that was
suing the state or the city would have
more money so it would make more sense
for them to do that than the kid because
if it wasn't the kids it wasn't for the
money
but if it wasn't the kid's fault the
parents wouldn't have sued the kid
probably because if he was just driving
and a bus hit them either way yeah
either way yes so let's just say it was
her fault
i wouldn't like she didn't want that to
happen obviously it was an
accident so me having a job where i have
to bring the kids in my car every day
and having an offer
like a chance higher chance of getting
to an accident i got freaked out i'm
like i still want the money coming in
i don't know you were getting paid this
was a business
this wasn't how much you got paid i
don't know i don't remember this was so
long ago i want i want to know the
digits how much how much
nice cash though all right that's what
i'm saying like i was like all right
that's not bad like they were very
generous
i got some good tips uh but i still
wanted to make sure that hey
if anything does happen it ain't mafa
did you set up that business deal or did
they just offer you money
they offered their offer oh they're like
oh maybe because i didn't ask them if
you take
weighing to school i'll give you 25 for
each time you drop
weighing off yeah no joke like i had i
think five
students uh drop off how many times how
much
time how many times did you get you got
paid every day well i would drop them
off
almost every day yeah i'll get a couple
hundred dollars
every day you got a couple hundred bucks
a week weekly per week still that's
pretty amazing yeah
especially in high school yeah and this
one's long money
save it smoke it what's that what
happened what did you do with that money
you smoking that she checked it in my
closet
the cash was just building up and i used
it all up on food
i'm just kidding no i saved it oh what
happened i created a bank account
and you know credit card started all
over the world you hell are responsible
i was i wasn't very i would've bought a
lot of stupid [ __ ]
no i was very good with money except
when it came to food anyway oh you are
really good with money though
but i don't have much money that's the
sad part anyway so that said i create a
contract
writing everything down and then i make
sure that if you're under 17
or actually 18 your parent had to sign
and you sign making sure that we're all
agreed i'm sure that contract was
bullcrap and it if anything did happen
it would be useless but i think the
parents kind of thought i was like this
girl is very responsible very
responsible
so i'll i'll not that i thought of it
because you went out the driveway and
you hit the garbage can
now i think about such a reckless driver
you still kind of are man that's why i
got so mad at her once because she was
driving so bad and i was telling her to
drive better but because she was being
so defensive
she was like i'm driving fine and then
she
uh i forgot what she did but i got so
mad i told her to pull over immediately
and i lectured her like i remember doing
that
and i and i saw myself as being my own
dad and i was like i am my father
right now you are but you
but that said i didn't create that
contract because i was a reckless driver
i created it for my own safe
and my family and now she is a great
driver now i am
i'm just a driver you are a responsible
driver more or less yes yes
but whenever we go somewhere she is
never allowed to drive i only drive
shout outs to me good job okay well that
story was a little bit more serious than
i thought it was i thought you were just
doing that just to be a goofball
just to make people sign stuff not you
mister why would i do what you're saying
dude
i ain't a joker that's why when i was in
high school
a couple of my friends too i wasn't in
the car but
they i i want to say i don't want to see
i don't think they were racing anybody
but it was in the middle of the night
and down this street specifically
there's not a lot of street lights
but the car whipped out of control and
um it flew into somebody's house
property
and they went through the fence and they
hit a tree or something like that
yes that's what happened and um a bunch
of all three of them went to the
hospital they were severely injured one
of my buddies still has the
the scar on his neck because the seat
belt cut into his neck
and then he still has like a huge scar
from it and yeah it was
it was pretty [ __ ] crazy and i
remember i was i remember even as a high
school kid
how [ __ ] up my mentality was because i
walked in and i saw this fool
in the the hospital and this whole had a
huge abandoned wrapped bandage
like white bandage wrapped around her
head and i couldn't stop laughing
because he looked like a mummy
i was like is it because you didn't see
any blood oh there was no blood
oh that's fine but it was all blood it
was pretty [ __ ] funny
man car accidents are real that's why
yeah that's why i get freaked out
sometimes when people just
they don't understand that when they're
driving a vehicle you are
driving a weapon that could kill people
right that's why i try not to text and
drive
right so it's it's like one of those
things that i i don't like that's why i
always when i drive i'm like here can
you text this
because i know especially because i have
a big suv now yeah yeah
when you had tesla you were just texting
me because i got
man i got that i got that autopilot baby
but i would only do that on the freeway
even though i shouldn't but i trusted
the you know the tesla thing a lot so i
would look down occasionally and do it
but without that autopilot i can't do it
it's too scary
when i was in college one of my friends
she lost her boyfriend to
a drunk driver um and he wasn't even
driving he was walking home
and that drunk driver ran him over and
crushed him in between a
light bulb and killed him holy [ __ ] yeah
that's why i like drunk driving and
driving your responsibility is something
that i i really can't [ __ ] with because
it's that it's that concept of of
understanding that yeah you can kill
yourself whatever you could be reckless
with your life but
all the other people that are involved
in the situation you know
they shouldn't be involved in your poor
choices that's why it's hard when people
like
drive drunk and there's no excuse now
because there's uber there's a lot of
these different apps that could take you
home especially now that we have those
have you ever had those dreams where you
like go if you all had a dream
have you had a dream uh when you're on
your freeway or something and you go
over the bridge and like you go so fast
and you
can't make the turn so you go off the
cliff
i've had those rooms so often that now
that when i'm
driving and i'm like making a turn on
the freeway and it's like over the
bridge
i get freaked out so i'm like oh i like
jitter
oh i hate i've had like i've definitely
had some repetitive dreams like i think
the
that scares me when i was a kid i don't
know what this means i have to look this
up
but i can i can
consistently had a dream where my mom
kept dying in front of me
and as a kid i kept having this dream
over and over and remember
my mom has the same dream about you my
mom always think i'm dying 24 7.
this is the funny thing about my mom
right anytime she dreams that something
bad's happening
she calls me up she goes don't do this
you're going to die
woman you are the worst telepath in life
apparently i should have died 86 times
and it has never [ __ ] happened well
with your luck
no but it has not happened all right i
know even recently she so my mom had a
dream
and this is what she told me she told me
that did we say this on the podcast
already
but she had a dream that marielle and i
were uh we bought a house together like
a really big house
but the reason why we bought this house
together
the reason why we bought this house
together was because apparently we came
by a lot of money
because we murdered somebody what yeah
and we murdered somebody and then we
buried that person what did we murder
don't know but this is what my mom told
me in the dream so in the dream she
walks into this house right and she says
that this house is really big
it has like it's like all white on the
inside and when she came up to me she
was really concerned and she was trying
to take me aside
and she goes hey like i know what
happened
and she goes i know what happened and
i'm like i'm playing aloof and i'm
telling her oh i don't i don't know i
don't know what you're talking about
but my mom said that she knew that you
killed somebody it wasn't us it was
actually you you killed somebody
and that i wasn't saying anything in
order to protect you
right and so my mom my mom was so
concerned because she goes
stop saying and so twice only so
my mom was very concerned because she
was worried
she goes i asked her what would you
concerned about she goes i was concerned
that
you know what if your youtube fans find
out and then you can't make a living
anymore
i'm like woman i killed somebody and
you're worried about my youtube fans
this woman is [ __ ] hilarious
and so she she was super concerned in
the dream that
um i had to hold on to this secret
because i loved you so much
about this person that you murdered that
we buried under this house
sounds like she just watched an intense
korean drama
and then fell asleep well she watched hi
bye mama i don't know how one
that sounds like a mix of parasite and
like dramatic drama
but i i had this reoccurring dream it's
funny even
when i talk about it now i can remember
it
but it's it's so traumatizing as a kid i
had it almost
i gotta say like at least like two three
years straight from like ages like eight
to like 11 or something like that and
one day i just stopped having that dream
but i kept having this dream that um
imagine like it's sunset
um let's say we're in san diego it's
sunset it's a grassy hill
and the the hill the grassy hill kind of
goes slopes up and as
my mom's running and as i see my mom
running i'm running after her wondering
where she's going
and is this a little davidson yes this
is me as an eight-year-old
so as i'm running you see like this
super
bright green grass and the sky is
colored in multiple colors
it's red it's it's yellow it's purple
it's and there's like rainbow colors in
there as well it's very beautiful the
sun is sending and as my mom's running
i'm running after and as i move past the
hill the hill
i start to realize how high we are and
you know i'm scared of heights i start
to realize how high we are and that hill
starts to turn into
um a cliff whoa and then as my mom's
going down i see my mom and she doesn't
realize it too and then she falls over
i run up and i grab her hand and then as
i'm grabbing her hand
i see my mom just dangling off and i'm a
kid and i'm holding my mom up and
in the dream i'm sobbing because i have
to hold my mom up
and as i'm holding my mama my mom's
screaming let go let go let go let go
let go in korean
and so like as a kid i'm trying not to
my
best i'm like no no no no no i'm
screaming screaming screaming my mom's
like screaming at me to let go but i
wouldn't do it
and then i see my mom drop and then i
wake up i kept having that dream
over and over as a kid and i would wake
up
bally are you tearing up no not really
but
that that dream i had so consistently
and i didn't know why i kept having that
damn dream
like why am i going to tell your parents
no i never told my mom about that but i
used to
i used to wake up like in i don't know
if it would be in the middle of the
night per se i can't remember that part
but i would always wake up just
sobbing my eyes out how was your
relationship with your mom back then
it was decent i think it wasn't as good
good as it is now
but i was always definitely a mama's boy
for sure but i don't know why as a young
kid i kept on having that same
repetitive dream
because i also had another repetitive
dream which i know a lot of people have
it's when you you get into a fist fight
in a dream and
no matter what you do you keep swinging
and swinging and swinging but it feels
like you have no strength in your limbs
and that person just doesn't get hurt
like you're not getting hurt but that
person you're just swinging at them and
nothing happens
i used to have that dream a lot i used
to have dreams i still do i'm trying to
run away from someone or somewhere
as fast as i can but i'm not going
anywhere that's not because i never hit
someone in my dream
not that i recall but i always had
dreams where i'm trying to run as fast
as i can but i'm just going nowhere
and i feel like my legs don't have any
energy so it's just it's kind of like
you're punching one day i gotta i gotta
bring up the i have it like in my
computer a bunch of these random notes
you should have one of those like uh
dream specialists come around maybe yeah
right now i told about this stream on
the podcast before but if people haven't
heard this and i think i told you this
one
where um i was
walking into a diner and the day is very
gloomy
it's cloudy it looks like it's about to
rain but it's not so all the skies are
really great
so i walk into this like very retro 19
whatever 60s diner right so a lot of
steel
red neon lights uh the boots the the
booth inside
it's it's all red when did this happen i
can't remember but this is this is a
very very vivid dream
um i walk into this to this diner i sit
down to order food and when i sit down
to order food this waitress comes up to
me
the waitress has her kid on her and the
kid is crying she's like apologizing she
goes i'm sorry my kid's crying a lot and
as she's trying to take my order i'm
like hey
it's okay you can leave your kid with me
like i'll watch your kid
um you could take my order go do what
you have to do and then come back
right and so like i'm holding the kid
serious
huh mood what was it a serious mood
serious mood whatever the mood like was
it was like just you or was it busy and
crowded
it's just a diner i don't remember that
much but uh i'm just sitting at the
diner and then everybody is
going about to think she goes thank you
so much she's very very appreciative
and she goes away so as i'm holding the
kid this angry man walks in right and he
starts
yelling at her or whatever what now they
started getting into a confrontation
and um as he as they get into a
confrontation
he looks at me and he's like he's
screaming at me because he thinks that
i'm with her because i'm holding the kid
right and so i leave the kid i go out
and i follow him
and as i follow him he kind of confronts
me and he turns around
points a gun at my face and then shoots
me point blink boom right in the head
and i die in my dream
and so people say that you're not
supposed to die in your dream and so
when i died i woke up
and i'm like what the [ __ ] happened and
i'm back at the same place outside the
diner
right back at the same place outside the
diner same setting super close
and then i go back inside the diner and
i'm kind of freaked out because it's
deja vu all over again
sit down order the food and the lady's
crying i'm like
i see the baby in her arm she's crying
she's freaking out i'm like hey you
could
leave the kid with me i'll watch the kid
she goes thank you so much everything's
the same again and i'm like this is
weird and i'm like there's a guy that's
about to walk through this door
the guy comes in starts yelling starts
doing his thing gets into my face you
know because he thinks that i'm with her
and i'm like okay well we should go take
it outside like
i was going to do again but this time as
i walk out and as i'm walking out i pull
a gun from behind my back
and he turns around and i shoot him in
shoot him in his head and i kill him and
then i wake up
whoa this is like inception it's weird
yeah i've i've had some i've
had some interesting ones i have some
weird vivid dreams but that one stuck in
my head pretty harsh like i could
if if i could draw i wish i could draw
really well i could draw what that diner
looks like
because of how vivid you can't describe
it to someone somewhat dry for you
yeah maybe but your dreams are always so
weird and interesting they're weird
they're my dreams are never linear
so i don't remember they're like when i
feel like when people recount their
dreams
they recount one specific thing i my
thing is like
um if i were to describe it it's like an
oil painting so if you took
one blob of paint here and then you put
another blob of paint on it and another
blob of paint
the first smear that you have is one
color and it spears into another one
into another one into another one that's
that's
that's how i recount everything so even
the last stream that i told you about it
went from me being into a school the
suddenly i'm into a dorm room suddenly
i'm in this
and so i remember all those random
sequences that happened within it which
is so odd
interesting yeah honestly when you told
me about that dorm and the bathroom i
was like oh this is an
80d drink that's that's a lot of my
dreams are kind of like cause you're
just like concentrating one thing and
then going to another
but i mean it's still very interesting i
don't i don't
i only remember like if you ask me do
you remember any dreams
um i have only one or two dreams that i
remember
and it's just uh one's a really sad
dream i think that's why i remember
it was um after my grandma passed away
that night i had a dream about her
and that dream was so vivid that i don't
till this day i remember
so clearly does it seem like it's really
it actually happened yeah
well because the thing is in the dream i
knew that she was dead so i was asking
her
why did you why did you leave yeah and
uh because it seemed so
real that it didn't feel like a dream do
you feel like that was her coming to you
in your dream
[Music]
maybe oh i can't talk about it yeah
maybe because she basically okay so what
happened in the dream is actually really
short
is that again i was running somewhere i
was running somewhere and
i fell and i hurt my knee and i turned
around
or i was sitting down crouched up
because it was hurting and i turned
around
and the person was behind me was my
grandma
and she had band-aids and stuff to like
you know
take care of my knee and i'm looking at
her i'm like grandma
why did you leave why
she had no response she was just quiet
she's fixing you up just fixing me
up and i was all crying
oh i'm like laughing and crying at the
same time i was all crying in my dream
and i looked at her and
oh so vivid i looked at her
and she wasn't looking at me she was
looking at me
taking care of it and i was just falling
because it was
the night that she passed away and i
woke up crying like this
was it the night that you passed away
that she was like that maybe it was your
harmony coming to you in your dream and
she was like trying to patch you up
maybe it could have been that's so you
know when you're when your grandma
passed away like i told you
it was your family was very fortunate
that you got to have a grandparent
that was with your family live with her
live with
uh she lived with your mom and on top of
that she got to see every single family
member that she had
before she passed away because it was at
new year's yeah it was a very fortunate
way i think like if somebody wanted to
pass away and on top of that too
it's not like your grandma was uh
she was like sick she was a paraplegic
or she couldn't feed herself she was
cooking so healthy
she was cleaning she was taking care of
herself she was perfectly
fine and she passed away on new year's
where everybody gets together so they
could see her
yeah and i mean like in the morning we
had
you know other relatives come to our
place because grandma used to live with
us
we had her come to i mean uh like the
aunties the cousins
you know great grandchildrens would come
and we would
all celebrate and she would cook
breakfast for us so we had her
you know we uh we have this what is it
uh rice cake soup
in the morning and so she uh prepared
that for us
we did the whole happy new year um
celebration
and actually that day is when i told my
family about you
yeah and so we all had a good time
and then everybody left and we decided
to meet again for dinner
um unfortunately before the dinner she
had a stroke and we had to go to the
hospital
i was away i heard the news and i
came to the emergency center and i
thought it was you know she was fine i
thought she was still alive
so everybody was waiting the waiting
room i came really late and that's when
the doctor
walked in and uh asked her where's my
grandma
and it was an old doctor and she was
like oh honey
she didn't make it yeah and i was like
when she said that you know on tv
when you get into a shock and all of a
sudden the
sound becomes like like the sound goes
away and
all you hear is like
[Music]
that's all i heard my dad was talking to
me about something because he heard the
news too
i could not hear him and it was just a
weird moment i was just like
as if things were twirling around and
there was a door
and inside that if i open that door
inside that room there are four
daughters
waiting for grandma to come back they
have no idea
and so and my mom's in there too so i
was like how are we gonna tell them
about this
yeah is this happening and i was just so
confused
but we had to tell the news and then we
went to go see grandma
um but overall yeah i mean she was
healthy
it was just a sudden stroke so
you know she didn't have any uh i mean
it was it was her time she was 90.
she was 96. yeah i think the i think the
hard part too especially like talking to
your mom
your mom felt felt like she could have
done
something and then uh yeah you know and
then when i talked to her for a short
stint you know i was having one-on-one
with your mom and i was just asking
like what could you have done no it's
your time to go it's your time to go
she was 96 years old you know she goes
well she was telling me she wasn't
feeling well and so she went up to go
sleep and rest
but then what you know you would have
you would have taken her to the hospital
because she said that she needed to
sleep
like i would have ever known you know
and i think that's the hard part where
even when even we always tell ourselves
that we're prepared
for that time when somebody leaves but
when it actually happens
it's hard to grasp it because for for my
grandma when she passed away
it was it was easier for me because of
everything that she was going through up
until that point right because she
suffered from like alzheimer's in a very
very severe formal way right she
couldn't
it went from her forgetting our names
for her not being able to remember
anything for her forgetting to take her
pills and that led to some other stuff
she had a stroke and everything else
and at the end of the story just to keep
the long story show she was short
she was in uh she was in hospice care
and she was getting fed through a tube
through her stomach
that's it so having to deal with that
emotional trauma all the way up until
that point
by the time she passed away it was i've
already dealt with it she was already
gone
she was already gone right and so those
are the emotions that i've already went
through so for you guys it was a lot
harder because you literally just saw
she cooked a huge meal for the whole
family and then
she disappears it was yeah it was hard
to accept
uh what happened but i am so grateful
that she was so healthy and her mind was
so sharp
we would ask her where things are
because she she knows everything
and i'm just grateful that she was
she was still grandma she was the
grandma that i recall
you know she yeah you got a really
clever mind you spend time with her the
way that she always
was yeah which like i said like when you
told me that she passed away
i mean obviously i didn't know her but i
all i could think about was how
fortunate you guys are that you actually
got to see her before she passed away
you got to share a final meal with her
before she passed away and she got the
cook for you guys before
she passed away nobody ever gets that i
don't know anybody who gets that
so yeah we thought she was gonna live at
least hundred we're like oh she's gonna
hit 100.
i thought my grandpa was gonna live 200
he died he died he died until he was 97.
it was pretty good you know he passed
away he had a i think um
he had like a slight stroke or something
and then he fell on his head
and then you know he had like uh i
caught like internal bleeding in his
brain and then at that point it was it
was done
so that's the thing i'm glad that she
didn't have to experience that
you know my grandpa went out in a very
in a very sad way
um but at the same time even for my
grandpa too it's like
unless somebody was next to him 24 7. we
couldn't have caught that
it happened in the middle of night when
he was going to the bathroom my parents
were asleep
and so it made me wonder about that when
my mom had to experience her you know
having that moment and calling that
ambulance um uh ambulance
yeah and for me i was outside and i
wondered too much
i'm wondering i always wonder is like
was i outside for a reason like would i
able to handle that if i saw my grandma
honestly it's hard man so i don't think
i ever told anybody this but two but
when my grandpa slipped and he fell
i didn't know what was going on right
because i was asleep i was in the other
room i was at the house
but then all i saw was a bunch of
firemen come in and take him away and
the only reason why my parents didn't
know what to do either they just thought
that he hurt himself
but when they when they picked him up
and he sent him back to his room he was
getting a little delirious
and so what my grandpa was doing was
before he was passing away he was laying
in bed and he kept on repeating this
prayer over and over and over again
he was he was praying to god constantly
just mumbling
in this prayer and then i freaked out
and then my my dad called my brother and
my dad my brother being a nurse he goes
you need to call
an ambulance right now right because my
dad didn't know what to do
he was just like oh is he hurt or is he
just praying like i don't know my
brother's like no
no this is very serious take him to a
hospital right now
and that's when we had to call the
ambulance and the firemen had to carry
him away what happened
how did he know that he had to call the
ambulance my brother heard
my grandpa just saying this prayer over
and over he goes no he's delirious like
he's seriously hurt
and so my brother thank god he's a nurse
told you know then to take him to the
hospital and they stabilized him a
little bit but he passed away in the
hospital
and there's a lot of weird regrets too
when you see somebody who pass away this
is why people talk about this thing
where they say
hey give somebody their flowers while
they're still alive right like
appreciate them michael steer here so
recently somebody passed away that i
really look up to jerry stiller
jerry stiller is ben stiller's father he
played george costanza's father in the
seinfeld
he played uh doug heffernan's um
father-in-law in king of queens super
amazing comedian
one of the funniest tv characters i've
ever seen in my life and he passed away
right
he lived a very long life but a lot of
people say give these people their
flowers when they're still around like
don't give it to them
after when they pass away and so what
happens a lot in these situations too
when i see it and it's really sad is
like
especially with my aunt right my aunt
when
her mom passed away and my grandpa
passed away she was
devastated right she was like oh my god
i can't believe she passed away
like i wish i was a better daughter i
wish this and that it's like
you could have wished that all all you
wanted but you could have done that when
you were here and the reason why i say
that
and i actually got really mad at her it
was put before the funeral
and i think she kind of erased it out of
her head but we were we were so when my
grandma was in hospice care i
was the one who had to take care of
everything paperwork whatever it was it
was me and my dad my dad would be there
and then i
had a part-time job and in between that
i would drive over to see if my grandma
was okay
so i had to literally watch her
deteriorate every week and so my
aunt never visited she never that's her
that's her mother
she never visited i think it was hard
for her to look at her mom right
but problematically speaking it's
you should take care of her that's when
she needs you right she needed you when
she was around
and she wasn't really there for her that
much too because they used to butt heads
a lot right
and so because they butted heads she
didn't really see her a lot and then i
remember when she passed away and
you see those you see these double doors
opened up and you see the stretcher take
her away and my aunt is
crying right she's bawling she's
screaming she's screaming like i can't
believe she passed away you know how
korean people born you know
doing all that other stuff right and
then i remember i looked at my aunt and
then she was so mad
and she was like this happened because
you guys didn't take care of her better
like yeah she said that to me and i
[ __ ] flipped on her like i remember
that moment like i [ __ ]
lost my [ __ ] and i was like that's
disrespectful
i would be mad too and i understand too
like she's like super traumatized but i
remember i flipped out on her i was like
you don't
ever get to say that because i was the
one that was here yeah
oh you're making me tear up cause i was
the one that had to watch her
you know just just deteriorate
so just hearing that she just pissed me
off and i remember like i was so mad at
her
but like i understand it's just like
if people don't know what it's like to
watch somebody just like wither away
it's hard it's so hard
like because you didn't get that you
know so like when i saw your grandma
pass away i was like you guys are very
lucky because i had to
i don't watch her just yeah i think it's
definitely different type of sadness you
know it's
like you had to hold that sadness
for years because you're watching it and
there's no there's nothing you can do
about it but to
just take care of as best as you can but
she's not gonna come back
she's not gonna die tomorrow and for us
at that point too you just wish they
would just pass away
because it's like yeah watching somebody
go it hurts it hurts because they're not
even
them like it's not the person that you
do and mind you like my grandma used to
[ __ ] me up dude she would beat my
[ __ ] ass
right your mom my grandma my mom didn't
get along very well
but at the end of the day like when she
got older and i got older she softened
up a lot
she wasn't the best to me but i don't
know what it is about something
what it is about family or somebody who
was around for you when you were younger
no matter how
badly they treated you you're still
really attached to them right because
she was not nice to me i think she
[ __ ] hated my guts
but you know as she got older she was
super super sweet
and that's i choose to remember all the
great things but when you get
you don't get to spend the time with the
person the way that you think that you
should
it sucks because i'm just watching her
in a hospital bed
all the time and then that was that went
on for a couple years and during those
two three years
my aunt never went to see her once not a
single time never went
wants to see her and then when she
passes away she causes the scene starts
screaming at people it's like
you don't you don't get to do that so
you you go do your own thing and i
didn't talk to her for almost like a
year after that because i was so pissed
at her because
it's your mom we're the ones who took
care of her i had to deal with that at
that time howell was i was 22
23 it's like i was super young you know
and i had to deal with this on a rig i
was doing adult grown-up [ __ ]
that i wasn't prepared for at that age
so having to do that and this is like
i think this is about a year or two
before i left to la so i was working
three part-time jobs and in between them
when i was doing that and going
being a full-time student i still found
the time to come in to check up on her
because that hospital that nursing
center is open 24 7 for family you could
go in whatever
go check up on her never saw her once
never just never to see how she's doing
she would call my dad hey is she okay
don't call don't call us to ask her
about that you go over there and you you
you see it for yourself
there were there were times too where we
had to see some terrible [ __ ] too
you have any idea how hard it is to
watch my grandpa go and see my grandma
and say hey
she's going to get better every time i
see that [ __ ]
i just see my grandpa hold my grandma's
head and go she's gonna get better every
day
i don't look at that [ __ ] so much and
then she comes and she goes you weren't
there i'm like come on
yeah it's hard i bet she regrets a lot
ah yeah i mean it's just not easy you
know these are the kind of things that
we hold and i think
it's hard to i mean you forgive and
forget but
that type of stuff is hard i mean these
are the things why i always call my mom
all the time like this is why
i can always look back and say i tried
i think that's one thing that i don't
have regret is that
oh
oh hold on you made me cry so much we
shouldn't do podcasts it's emotional
why'd you talk about your grandma doing
though you talk much you're talking
about dreams these are
the things i have nothing to do with the
only dream i recall that i was like what
do i remember anything that was the only
one
but um uh the night before she
or yeah the day before she passed away
i think about the past two years when i
came back from taiwan
i was really i was i was living in the
house so i was
with her all the time so i had i didn't
think much of it but i did realize that
how
small she has become like physically she
was so petite
and really cute so i just started
recording her
being with her all the time you know buy
stuff that makes her happy you know she
loved it now she loved frappuccino
and you know obviously she drank just
enough where
um it's not it's healthy for her
and i would record her and
looking back all those thank god i have
those footage
and also just looking back i think i
told myself like i think i did well i
think she was happy with me
because she like looking at those videos
like she loved me so much and she's
happy to see me
she's the only one where i actually
cried coming back and
giving a hug because i missed her and
um she did the same thing too like she
just started crying because she's
you know she missed me so
i cried sometimes because i miss her a
lot but oh
i don't think i have that moment where
it's like i regret not doing
good for her yeah it's it's hard to say
for me too because i don't
think i've ever i think you did your
best too
i did my best i mean i think i gave her
roses when she could you know
she i mean like i said she used to be my
ass so
but yeah just going back to that topic
of just kind of respecting and loving
people at that moment
yeah it's super important it's hard
it's hard even when i think about like
it's not that i try not to think about
it it's just
like i do it out of respect but yeah i
can i can relive those moments it makes
me so sad
just to just to go back and think about
it and see how she went out was
was so sad like i'm pretty sure she
didn't want to go that way but we
we i remember i talked to you about this
too where
it's kind of we were very fortunate
you were very fortunate in that case but
seeing some of our other grandparents
and other people's grandparents to see
how they live their lives and how they
went out i think it's a reflection of
who they were when they were younger
yeah right my grandma was a very angry
angry person and
she was a sweetheart yeah and the way
she went out you know she suffered from
i mean obviously i don't know the
studies behind this but
living with a lot of anger and a lot of
stress and then how she went out wasn't
that great
i know some other people's grandparents
too that were they were like that and
every single grandparent that i know
anyways
that were very happy they were very
chill and relaxed they
they had the best mental health when
they were older and they lived the best
light before they passed so it's like i
really want to enact that stuff in my
life
and for sure me too i want to grow up
like my grandma
because i don't recall her yelling at me
ever
because she i grew up she raised me
basically like she lived with us
since i was born and i don't recall her
ever being
angry raising her voice um
and she just had such a pure heart
bottle of soju under her bed
she had a few bottles of soju and fruits
that would come out under her bed for
some reason but
that was her late night snack that was
her midnight snack yeah
watching k drama all day the one thing i
did wish is i wish i could have taken
her out a lot because i realized
all she does is she cleans up the place
and stuff you know
that's her exercise because we have two
floors and then she would just watch
k-drama all day
and i was like oh it would have been
nice if i could take her out more maybe
she just enjoyed that though
she did yeah she probably exhausted too
she went out
well guys um that wraps up this episode
of the genius cry podcast oh i didn't
yeah let's talk about my grandma i
didn't think you would either fool
why did you talk about dreams no we got
no we got boogers and now we got the
close-up camera you cry
you make me cry i'm in my cell cry dude
gangster tears homie you feel me
i cry all the time it doesn't matter
yeah i mean yeah you made me really
relive some old thoughts that i actually
kind of forgot about to be honest with
you like i
i kind of forgot about all that stuff
like i i really did forget about
watching my grandpa just like hold my
grandma's hand and say telling us that
she would get better
that was hard for me man like because i
because i had to
take my grandpa to go see my grandma
because my parents were at work
so he was like do you see her she's
getting better and i'm like [ __ ] man he
doesn't know
well he loves herself of course i mean
they were together for 4 000 years
i mean my grandpa's first book was the
bible dude
ethel i'm talking about the original
bible that was old dude
he was born before cars were
manufactured same with your ground
anybody that's 90 something years old
cars weren't cars were manufactured like
regularly
i think this first vehicle was a donkey
that was hella old
when he was a little kid yeah i guess
yeah they went through
how many world wars world wars all of
them yeah yeah
yeah well that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast have funny half
series you don't know what you're going
to get on this but you're going to take
away something huh
good good heartfelt stories and all that
other [ __ ]
um yeah man you guys could catch the
genius brain podcast on spotify itunes
everything else
uh we ain't no joe rogan with 100
million dollar deal baby but we can get
there real soon because you already know
a no podcast like a genius brain podcast
every thursdays and sundays you know
when those uploads are up and i will
catch you guys next time